we've certainly come a long way um
i think we're just going to keep
improving the more we're together the
more we're talking about football the
more we're
um
trying to be on the same page you know
the better it is and we got a big test
this weekend
one of the great teams in the nfl and
consistently been one of the great teams
for a long time
and we're going to play a great football
game
tom brady talking about his team and the
looming showdown against the new orleans
saints who have beaten the buccaneers
twice this year but peter game one was
way back in week one when tom brad i
still remember
the first shot from that game on the
late afternoon window of the first
sunday and you see tom brady in a tampa
bay buccaneers uniform for the first
time and even though you've known for
months it's going to happen it was
jarring and the whole experience the
whole thing had to be jarring for him
and they they gave him a decent game he
scored the first touchdown of the day a
rushing touchdown and it wasn't a
blowout by any means then they get blown
out week nine
and now they get together in what will
be game number 18
for tom brady with the buccaneers the
full season has been played this is now
year two he's he knows this offense they
know him and the x factor for this one
peter antonio brown
he's he's in game speed game shape ready
to go and the last time he played the
saints it was in the superdome well the
last time we played in the superdome
against the saints because he did face
them in week nine but in the superdome
for the steelers his last game with
pittsburgh 14 catches 185 yards and two
touchdowns so if if antonio brown is
indeed in game shape and if he hasn't
lost much in two years that's going to
be a potent weapon so this is just a
very different team than the buccaneers
team that the saints beat twice earlier
this year and it's been a long time
since the last time they met
mike i'm going to tell you why you were
on to something in analyzing this game
um and i'm going to take you back to
that super bowl
um
when he when tom brady engineered the
28-3 comeback uh to beat the atlanta
falcons in overtime
and a week after that game i sat with
tom brady for
i don't know 90 minutes or so
um in in montana of all places and i
asked him
flat out i said some of your throws in
overtime
were just
fabulous
because
what he did in overtime and late in the
fourth quarter if you remember remember
this this uh you know
absolute run-of-the-mill receiver they
had that year named chris hogan okay
and he threw these back shoulder passes
to chris hogan like
everybody on the falcons kept running
chris hogan stopped turned around and
came back for the ball on three separate
passes late in that game
and i asked tom brady specifically
i said
you and chris hogan basically how about
chris hogan winning this game and are
really helping to win this game
it looked like you two guys were the
only people in the stadium who knew what
you were about to do
and he said to me the following words
peter
122 practices
so when you hear this little cliche
fester what you think is a cliche fest
at the sound bite that we just played at
the top of this hour well you know you
know we're we're getting better together
we get better every day all that stuff
that's not a cliche to tom brady
he believes that in his heart
that he is going to be better
on on sunday in this game because of all
the practice time he's had with scottie
miller
you know with chris godwin with mike
evans with antonio brown with cameron
braid he's going to be better and
they're going to be better so i do think
it's a different team on sunday that the
saints are going to have to beat
and i think the fact that the saints won
the first two games put so much more
pressure on them and that second one
came so easily
you know it reminded me a lot of what
happened with the browns and the
steelers on sunday night where just it's
just an avalanche and before you know it
the game's over
i
if it doesn't go easily for the saints
early on if they find themselves in a
real fight you know that that's that's
that's going to make them a little shaky
and and the saints are the team that has
had the heartbreaking loss in the
postseason peter three straight years
now and i don't care what anyone says
you are gonna have coaches players
trainers everyone
thinking
or trying not to think but having this
nagging sense somewhere
in their souls
here it comes
here it comes it's going to happen again
some way somehow it's gonna happen again
and yeah i think this is the worst
possible time to get the buccaneers with
tom brady because they've had so much
time together and the method to the
madness from bruce arians earlier this
year when he's calling guys like tom
brady out well what does it do it pushes
them to get better and they've gotten
better and they've hit their stride
coming out of their bye week they've
been great and but for that first half
when they were shut out by the falcons
well they still turned it around and
kicked their butts so it was a positive
but they they've been great and they're
going to be very very tough to beat on
sunday night even though the saints have
beaten them twice before drew brees
turns 42 today happy birthday drew brees
and look i
you know no one expects tom brady to
retire after this season but
that's the other element that adds to
this game for the saints
this may be it for drew brees and i
think people on the sideline people in
the locker room they're going to be very
aware of that and i don't know if that's
a positive or a negative that a loss
means that's it for drew
here's the thing mike you know drew
brees
15 years in new orleans
when he
landed in new orleans to sign his
contract
and was taken from the airport to the
saints facility
he passed
uh all sorts of gigantic refuse in the
road cars up on blocks
uh the the city was a ruined
city
that spring
the mayor of new orleans when i was in
there to do a story on the saints before
they drafted reggie bush
the day that i that i was there for a
couple of days i i was there one day
president bush
came into the city to the lower ninth
ward and sean payton and mickey loomis
were there
and it was all about and you know loomis
and and bush and payton were together we
got to get this done the mayor was there
so the mayor ray nagin
says to me that day
he says
i just hope that the saints can stay
here for one more year at least
so we can get on our feet
and do you know why they've been there
and why now they are a rock solid
franchise in the city of new orleans
they're there
in an overriding way because of the
contributions of drew brees now there's
a lot of people you know loomis has
built this you know the foundation of
the franchise payton has been such a
great coach they've had great players
but i would say the one guy who's done
this who's most responsible is the great
play of drew brees
and mike
i know this
if drew brees retires at the end of this
year which we all assume that he will
he is not going to want his last game
ever
in the city that he helped rebuild
in the city that if he ran for mayor he
would win unanimously
in the city that is his adopted city
that he's raised his kids in for half of
every year
you know for the last decade plus
he is not going to want his last game
in the superdome to be a loss what does
that mean i think it means something i
don't know how much it'll mean
especially because the guy on the other
side is named tom brady but i do think
it's meaningful
i think it means we're going to have one
hell of a game on sunday night that's
what it means because something's got to
give here they both can't advance and
it's either going to be
an extremely disappointing end to tom
brady's first season with the team other
than the patriots and it's hard to say
getting to the final eight is
disappointing but this guy's always
driven to get to the top of the mountain
and we've seen it so many times for
crying out loud he's played nine super
bowls in 20 years but it's going to be
whatever the aftermath it's going to be
uh more devastating
than the usual playoff loss and the
usual playoff loss at this level is
devastating but you know the thing is
the saints have been there and done that
and seen that and lived that and can
they overcome that minneapolis miracle
the anniversary was three years ago
yesterday the debacle in the nfc
championship game with the non-call of
pass interference from two years ago in
the superdome last year in the superdome
the loss to the vikings in overtime with
the the subtle but very obvious push by
kyle rudolph to secure the game-winning
touchdown uncalled offensive pass
interference uh man it's you know look
they got their super bowl win even
though it was a long time ago
they desperately would love to get
another one but
you know i i i had thought going into
the playoffs
that the buccaneers
path to the super bowl
was easiest if they could avoid the
saints
i'm now thinking maybe the saints path
to the super bowl would be the easiest
they could avoid the buccaneers
yeah i mean
mike we've both made great arguments in
the last seven minutes about why you
don't want to play
both teams right now
the bucks because brady now having
gotten to know all the receivers on this
team him got you know very interesting i
was talking to somebody in the bucks
organization two days ago and said hey
what do you think and just opening a
conversation he goes
you know i've been thinking a lot about
this and in the first game of this
season i can tell you and it's not i'm
not kidding around you still had some
guys
his receivers
who were in awe of tom brady who really
couldn't believe that tom brady was
their quarterback we have no explanation
for the second game you know the 38-3
loss it was a total abomination nothing
but now
everybody on this team doesn't look at
tom brady as a trophy they look at him
as a teammate and so that's just another
way to suggest that
i just i just how do you not call this
the game of the weekend i mean it's just
i think it's just an absolutely
tremendous
uh it's tremendous
and that array of weapons just
incredible to think what he came from in
new england and what he has between mike
evans chris godwin antonio brown scotty
miller rob gronkowski for crying out
loud cameron break to
to to be that guy that no one's paying
attention to because they're they're so
focused on everyone else he'll get you
if he gets a chance and then the running
game london fournette stepped up last
week when ronald jones reinjured his
quad in pregame warm-ups it's it's uh
and the offensive line that's the other
thing too peter you know the saints have
a great defense they got a great pass
rush but that offensive line was so good
against the washington murderers row
they give tom brady time to throw the
ball down the field we had the numbers
earlier this week he was 22 of 40
against the washington football team he
averaged over 17 yards per completion
and nine and a half per attempt even
though he completed almost only half of
his passes he still averaged nine and a
half yards per attempt he's getting the
time to get the ball down the field
and that's really going to matter this
week because
obviously the saints are really going to
try to pressure them they've got a very
physical secondary and so this is it's
going to be a great test for brady but
mike you mentioned at the beginning of
your first uh statement about this game
you talked about antonio brown
and look
antonio brown
has not done
one thing all all steam now they've been
his team now they've been he got charged
with that weird uh you know thing at his
condo complex uh around hollywood uh
which is on the other side of the state
but that wasn't when he was
with the bucks and
i've i've been told that he has been
beyond a model citizen
and it is all because it's like brady's
dad
and brady's basically told him look i
don't i don't know the exact words but
i'm sure
that brady has told him look
this is it
it's the last chance saloon buddy
this is your you know if if you know if
you're gonna have somebody like me stick
up for you
you know and and come into a place if
you somehow someway mess this up you'll
never have another chance again and i
think he knows it
and i think mike
don't underestimate what his best
behavior
is saying to the league office it's
saying that i have drawn a line of
demarcation in my life
i am not that guy anymore i am not the
pittsburgh guy anymore i'm not the
oakland guy anymore i've made a new life
for myself so do not kick me out of this
game you know i i honestly believe that
he's using this to show the nfl
i can be a good guy just look at me
and and so i think he's been managed
well
by the bucks
and i think he's been managed well by
tom brady and he also has reached the
point where he realizes
uh that he has he's got two strikes on
him
and uh he's got a great pitcher on the
mound he can't screw up again
and it's interesting to see what next
year will bring to chris godwin do to
become a free agent it could be mike
evans and antonio brown as the primary
receivers next year when tom brady
inevitably is back in tampa bay for a
second season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports